madame monsieur bonsoir le procès en
révision de patrick dils s'est achevée
par un dernier coup de théâtre la cour
d'assises pour mineurs de la marne l'a
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour le meurtre des deux
enfants de montigny-lès-metz commis en
86 après six heures de délibéré les
jurés n'ont pas suivi l'avocat général
qui avait demandé l'acquittement sur ce
procès extraordinaire le compte-rendu
l'analyse de notre envoyé spécial
dominique verdeilhan
un verdict rendu dans un silence pesant
les jurés ne regardez pas l'accusé et
tout a basculé au moment le président a
annoncé qu'à la question sur la
culpabilité de patrick dils la cour
d'assises avait répondu oui patrick 10
étaient à nouveau reconnus coupables
patrick dils était à nouveau condamné
pour double meurtre étonnant patrick 10
qui n'a pas bronché à l'énoncé du
verdict il s'est levé il a quitté son
box la salle d'audience sans même se
retourner vers la salle vers le public
vers sa mère qui s'était effondré
quelques minutes plus tôt alors après ce
verdict force est de constater que
révision ne veut pas dire forcément
innocence ne veut pas dire forcément
acquittement malgré la présence supposée
sur les lieux du crime de francis
heaulme
malgré une accusation qui avait requis
l'acquittement patrick dils a été
condamné à 25 ans de réclusion
criminelle l'excusé de minorité qui
aurait permis une peine de vingt ans lui
a été refusé pourquoi 25 ans difficile
de le dire en tout cas après 14 ans de
détention provisoire patrick dils est en
droit de demander une libération
conditionnelle
ses avocats s'interrogent sur
l'opportunité de faire appel de ce
verdict il n'y aura donc peut-être pas
de troisième procès de patrick dils